now i know this might be hard to believe but
certain people once they start carbs they cannot
stop so recently i had a person who reached
out and wanted some help because they were
slightly addicted to carbs they wanted to start
keto but they had this addiction how do they
go about it so i decided to create a video
for this person all right we've been trained
since birth to consume sugar okay it's in baby
food it's in all of our foods and uh you know go
trick-or-treating and you get all this candy and
every holiday and cookies etc etc and what happens
inside our body every time we do this is we start
to develop um an addiction um and that involves
two neurotransmitters one is dopamine which is
involved with pleasure sensation and then we have
serotonin which is involved with the happiness
sensation now i used to have an addiction i mean a
periodic craving for ben and jerry's ice
cream i got caught up in this uh eating a pint
every night before i went to bed type situation
over i would say a year i would be obsessed about
it i would be thinking about it all day long
and eventually if i didn't consume it i had this
pressure or stress build up that may be physically
uncomfortable but as soon as i started consuming
this delicious ice cream i felt satisfied happy i
felt like i was surviving i could finally breathe
again for about about a minute now of course this
was artificially making me satisfied happy and
feeling like i was surviving when i actually
was feeling very miserable the rest of the day
and not really surviving health-wise so what you
have to realize is that every time you give in to
this craving you're going to get more cravings
over time it's going to happen it's going to
become stronger and stronger over time and it's
very interesting to me that your body can get into
a state physically where it demands this sugar
this addiction is real and it will literally
control you to a point where you're completely
out of control so what can you do at this point
number one you need to stop eating completely you
need to start fasting immediately because what's
gonna happen instead of eating food you're gonna
eat no food and your body is gonna have to switch
over there's gonna be a little uncomfortable
transition period but it won't be too bad or your
body will start to switch to ketosis and then when
you start burning fat for fuel your brain actually
starts to heal and reset because the receptors
for these neurotransmitters are so messed up they
need to be reset the absolute best way to do it is
simply start fasting i would recommend minimally
24 hours to 48 hours and if you can actually do
exercise light exercise walking that would be even
better because you can burn off that sugar that
you just consumed so just get it out of the system
get your body into ketosis and then your brain
will feel better the interesting thing about
the brain is that if given the choice the
brain will prefer ketones over sugar any
day it's very therapeutic and as soon as that
happens you start to shift to be more in control
over this addiction all right number three you
have to be very careful to avoid the triggers
get all the junk food out of the house including
those chips that you have up in the cupboard that
you've been hiding make it difficult for you to
get this junk food especially late at night when
you're kind of bored so many people at night
they're not even hungry they're just going
through the cupboards looking for something they
don't even know what they're looking for but maybe
something salty and crunchy maybe something sweet
but you need to get the junk out of your house
very important when you're fasting don't
read cookbooks okay especially for desserts
you want to avoid any type of trigger
including pictures of recipes or desserts
because dopamine is all about anticipating
pleasure as soon as you eat this food
you don't continue to increase dopamine dopamine
is kind of a precursor to actual eating it so
as soon as you look at a picture or smell food
you instantly start increasing the dopamine and
that is going to create a controlling factor over
your body let's say for example you're driving
your bike down your neighborhood and it's dinner
time and you can smell spaghetti cooking in the
from someone's house that would be bad don't
do that so smells are very powerful kentucky
fried chicken they pump out all these different
smells so they can lure you into that facility
avoid any and all environments that can tempt you
and lastly b vitamins are are crucial vitamin b1
will completely handle this right here okay so use
that through nutritional yeast to help curb your
addictions i'm sorry your cravings hey before
you go real quick i have a course entitled how
to bulletproof your immune system it's a free
course i want you to take it and here's why
here's you here is your environment everyone
is focused on this over here avoiding
your environment but what about here what about
strengthening your immune system that's what's
missing this course will show you how to
bulletproof yourself and so you can tolerate
and resist your environment much better by
strengthening your own immune system i put
a link down in the description right down
below check it out and get signed up today